welcome to the microsoft research summit
uh this is a session on
software productivity i'm neil
sunderesen i'm the vice president of
data and ai
in the developer division of the cloud
and ai i'm debating the division of
microsoft so today i'm going to walk you
through several generations of
innovations and work in
software productivity
and what foundational elements
contributed to these innovations a lot
of the stories i'm going to share
the concepts i'm going to share are
through my own personal lens and my own
personal journey starting off as a
compiler engineer to
today uh introducing ai into developer
productivity in the cloud world
so let's start at the beginning uh when
we think about automation and when you
think about automation through software
what is automation automation is
basically taking mundane manual tasks
and
using computers to automate them and
this task could be like converting one
form of data to another or
what i saw when i was learning computer
science was a lot of converting
a lot of programs in one language into
another language right so the number of
computer programming languages are
invented and this was a programming task
now if you had one program to translate
you could write a third program that
translates from one to the other but
what if you had a lot of programs
translate from one source language to
lab programs in target languages
now you could hire a programmer to
translate each of these programs but
that would not be scalable and would not
be smart
but you know you have compilers um or
code generators or transpilers or you
know call it depending upon the source
in the target language the source
language could be a human language or a
programming language the target language
could be an architectural language like
machine language or a program another
programming language and so on
um but instead of having all these
programmers write programs for
individual uh translate individual code
you have compilers or this transpilers
that will write that that is basically a
program you can have one programmer
write one program that translates code
in any one language into any other
language now what is the foundation of
being able to do this because the source
and the target language have grammars
associated with them so in this
generation the grammar was the
foundation of innovation of developer
productivity or software productivity so
let's see go for beyond what i just gave
an example of compiler
what if if you have programs in many
languages so let's say there are m
source languages and and target
languages now if you were to do it in
the traditional way you would end up
writing m times n compilers or
transpilers or translators and that
would be inefficient but if you look at
these programs they have a general task
what is the task that they are doing
their task is to take a program in one
language and translate into a program in
another language now the first level of
innovation came about when we had
retargetable compiler code generation
now what that meant what you could do is
you could have an intermediate language
then you could write a bunch of
translators going from the source
language to the intermediate language
then you have a translators going from
the intermediate language to the target
language so now what you've done is
you've taken this job of writing n times
m transformers to m plus n transformers
so that was a big innovation and as new
architectures are invented as new
programming languages invented these
tasks were automated that way but you
could go even a step further
now what is the task of actually
translating it so there is a source
grammar and there is a target grammar
now the task is actually taking
constructs in the source grammar and the
source language and writing
transformations for those each of those
constructs in the target language which
means there is a structure to these
translators which is basically
transformation rules from source to
target now that itself is a language
which means that itself has a as a
grammar associated with with it because
it has a grammar associated with it you
can actually write just the translation
rules and have write one computer
program that drives through the
translation rules and translates program
in any given programming language to any
other programming language now if you if
you take you know these programming
languages the transformation rules have
a lot of similarities in them so you can
even think of taking it to the next step
and
automating the even the
writing of the translated code generator
generator part where you could
automatically generate the code
generator so there are multiple levels
of innovations that could happen because
of grammars
so the whole idea of this generation of
innovation was why write code when you
can generate them and what was essential
for this the notion of grammar the
schema was essential for this kind of
automation
and there were cases where grammar was
absent then what you could do is you
could use examples of programs in those
languages and
automatically generate those grammar or
try to automatically generate those
grammars but these kinds of
approaches work only for small domain
specific languages like regular
expressions
now what was a big myth at least in my
own personal experience what was a big
miss i was writing these tools that
could generate
lots of code or translate millions of
lines of code in one source language to
target language but what i didn't see is
i didn't think of all of this code as
data
now we we were very driven by grammars
and we always worried about having good
schema and writing good transformation
roles but we didn't think of all of
these programs that were written and
generated as data but all of this was
about to change because what happened
the internet came about now with the
internet what happened we got a ton of
data
there was markup data image data textual
data and a lot of this data is for human
consumption
if you look at commerce set your
transactional data your behavioral data
etc but what we lost in the process was
schema or grammars right there was no
grammar with it
and but because we had so much data the
modern data science was born
we the focus was on how to process the
data how to apply algorithms to data and
how to solve new kinds of problems that
could not have been solved before using
this data so i'm going to give you a few
examples
now in this generation as we see data
became the foundation of innovation for
productivity
and
and there was a great paper written by
folks at google about the unreasonable
effectiveness of data
and the paper said simple models can
work better than with more data so you
don't really need complex models a lot
of the machine learning algorithms or
the data science algorithms we did at
that time are simple regression
algorithms feature based or you know
engineered features of simple number of
features but
add more and more data to it to get
effective solutions i'm going to give
you a few examples of that for example
we built search engines and recommender
systems just based upon volumes of data
and we could solve recommendation
problems when users come to the website
by
looking at their data and see what next
product are they going to buy based upon
what they bought before but when are
they going to buy so we could solve
problems that are more human than the
kind of problems we could solve before
now also data brought other fields like
economics and other social science
fields closer to computer science the
whole area of digital economics was born
we could answer questions using data
like
what kind of strategies do people follow
in online markets or we could say what
happens when we introduce internet sales
tax we could answer causation questions
we could answer counterfactual questions
we could answer elasticity questions
what if i increase the sales tax by one
percent what would happen
right we could say what what could
happen when
new smartphones were introduced how is
it going to in
inform and evolve
the way commerce is done we could talk
about badging and how reputations work
on the internet etc and all of this was
due to the
effectiveness of data and simple
algorithms simple statistical algorithm
but we could do some solve some real
complex problems and even if you look at
things like computer vision and speech
we didn't really need complex algorithms
and up until that point a lot of work in
speech and vision were rule-based and
used very small amount of data but you
could look at large amounts of data and
look at their patterns and tease out
elements of those patterns and just do
science in them we could put in build an
entire vision search by just looking at
the meta
at the data and the elements of the
colors in the data etc to figure out the
style of the
let's say if it is a piece of clothing
the style of the clothing the color the
clothing the patterns of the clothing
etc
so the internet allowed us and the data
availability allowed us to build systems
that were at scale that could process
data at scale and solve problems that
were extremely data-driven which was
quite different from before but again
things were about to change um
with new hardware available gpus
available etc and let's look at that
third phase
now um six years ago i joined microsoft
and a colleague of me mine showed this
picture to me and this was for a picture
from the developer division so now this
audience of ours are developers
developers who
um you know
write you know we have an audience of
about 20 plus million developers for
whom we build tools right and the way we
look at the software development cycle
is there's an inner loop which is where
the developer writes code debugs the
code and um
you know enters the code and so on and
so forth and on the outer loop which is
basically more core screen tasks like
pushing into production running bills
you know bug patching doing pull
requests you know documenting the code
testing the code and doing ci cd or
continuous integration etc now the
question comes now can we automate this
process or can you do things that will
benefit the developer
by building the right kind of tools for
them so again coming with a data
background i was asking the question
what kind of data do we have
so if you look at the internet today i
mean
repositories like github have tons and
tons of data
code data even in companies within
themselves inside of them have tons of
data in multiple languages so we got a
lot of code data this is the first time
that actually i saw code as data
and then a lot of tools like the
canvases on which their developers write
code like vs code visual studio
notebooks you know
azure shelves etc and there are user
forums like reddit and stack overflow
and many other forums from which we can
get data so if we can take all of this
interaction data can we build build
interesting tools with this interaction
data that's
well that was the question that i wanted
to answer
but i wanted to start spawn so we wanted
to start small so what is the first
thing we could do number one first we
need to know
what can we do with this data can we
build tools that address the needs of
the large community of 20 plus million
developers
you know and
can we teach a machine or can we build
systems that can learn enough to
automatically do stuff or assist
developers to do the task with
reasonable accuracy
and the third question was can we do
this over and over again so can we teach
the machine once and repeatedly use it
to do many tasks
we know that it won't be perfect because
a lot of the stuff this machine learns
is probabilistic but if you can build a
system that's open to repair then we can
do very well so basically the goal was
to automate the mundane because people
make mistakes
engineers make mistakes doing mundane
tasks and when there are complex tasks
that they can't keep in their head or in
the system you know canvas can the
machine assist with these complex tasks
so we with this in the background we
started with a very simple um goals so
if you look at developers writing code
about 30 percent of the code they write
are api calls
and if you look at any kind of
intellisense that you know most students
offer today they offer intellisense
where you know the call is listed in
alphabetical order or frequency order so
we ask the question can we do something
better
right so which means i'm in a certain
section of my code i've written a bunch
of code before and i'm going to continue
writing what is the call i should make
at this point of time
so a simple thing to do is take all the
programs and build flow graphs out of
them
and once you have the flow graphs you
can use ml to say what call would follow
what call right so you build a simple
markov model markup chain model and
answer the question of given a package
it made call a i have not made any call
at all what call would be the next call
i would make and make the suggestion
now this was a very naive but at the
same time useful thing to do
when we shipped this the developers were
super impressed with this they were very
happy that we provided with them a tool
that was more intelligent than what they
were used to and this is an unusual
experience for machine learning folks
because typically when we build models
they work really well offline and when
we bring them online the the performance
is much lower here we start with user
feedback actually the users were a lot
more happier
so with that we at that time we thought
maybe we could do more and the reason is
that with this kind of a model the model
was not scalable
it was not scalable
because for every package every class
you have to build this chain
so we went with the sequence to sequence
a deep learning model and improved the
performance in a sense it could get more
coverage and it could make better
recommendations but the model was a lot
a lot larger and then we have challenges
when we deploy these models into
production
um so we had to do a whole bunch of
other engineering things to make sure
that they work well
now right around this time great
innovations were happening in the ai
area right great innovation hardware um
we're getting much better hardware with
the gpus and so on much better
algorithms in deep learning and great
ways to process data
now what we saw that from the this
models that were built out of this the
combination of these things really
powered the early nlp work in the in the
last five years the elmo and bird which
were which are not as big models as we
see today um basically change the
foundation of nlp research is done
right and then more
recently models like
megatron and then gpt3 and t5 are even
more larger and even more complex and
even more generalized and the nice thing
about these things systems are that they
you don't need to now do any any more
task specific features when we when we
deploy these models
now
also they consume extensive volumes of
data they tend to have general
intelligence so they have generally
ai intelligence and they can be easily
adapted as well so now the theory is
that now because they have the general
intelligence we can do some slight
tweaks in the downstream tasks that we
might want to solve and these downstream
tasks can be solved either through the
conversation with the systems if the
systems are large or just by fine tuning
so there are a lot of opportunities
related
to this ai revolution that we can apply
to development productivity
so we come to the third phase of um
what is offered to us as foundation now
we have ai models as foundation this
third generation
right so what are the opportunities here
now we have the ability to capture the
universe of domain information so think
about all programs have written all
images ever seen all videos ever created
and what kind of intelligence can you
gain by uh you know mining them and and
building models on top of them it has
the capability to learn from different
modalities you can have text and images
or text and programs and so on you can
mix and match them and and have higher
intelligence on top of it then you can
encode this language in
higher volume in high volume in higher
dimensional forms
and you can express this knowledge in a
way that can you can adapt to specific
tasks so if you ask the machine what
have you learned you really don't want
to know what the machine has learned but
you can adapt whatever it might know in
for a specific task that you might want
to do
and then this you can extend this
knowledge either through conversation
with the with the machine or by tuning
it to achieve these specific tasks i'm
going to give you some examples of these
right but there are some practical
questions that arise right is the
machine learning something or is it just
memorizing
has it seen everything that has ever
been to see so for example if i push all
the programs that i've gained off of the
internet through this machine or follow
if you're seeing all the text i've seen
on the internet to this machine
has it's seen everything that is there
to see and the next thing that that one
writes whether it's code or whether it's
text is just going to be a combination
of the parameters of what he has already
seen or does it even matter right that
it has seen everything or it has not
seen everything at all
so there is some confusion here that is
it intelligence or is it knowledge right
or does it even matter
now the bigger question is do will you
trust what it does
will you trust what it does because um
you know what is the cost of being wrong
when it's right you're happy when it's
wrong you know how much is it going to
cost you depending upon the task you're
applying for
then when we go into practical systems
for deploying these models you ask the
question what are the training costs how
much how big a hardware do i need how
much energy does it consume what are the
cost for influence who's going to pay
for it are my customers going to pay for
it am i going to pay for it what's
what's roi on this kind of influence
cost and what are the scaling cost right
if i want to deploy to large number of
users or or solve larger problems what
does it even cost what are the
deployment costs so these are questions
we often ask in product groups
then we have other questions about the
data and the models what is how good is
the data what is the quality of the data
what kind of biases do you see pretty
much any data that you did that you
gather at large scale it has this
you know a zip property where you've got
a heavy head and a long tail
right if you if you get all the text on
the internet quite likely most of them
would be english but if you see these
smaller languages you know smaller
tribal languages will almost see no
examples of that if you take all the
code on the internet quite likely you
will see popular languages show up a lot
and the less popular languages will have
very few examples of that does that bias
the decision that you make off of this
machine
and what what about privacy
what if what if people have put in
information in there that the machine is
smart enough to violate their privacy
what about security can people inject
you know
bad code into the system so that it it
produces secure code and who owns all of
this data right if i write code and put
it on the internet do i own it does and
does that machine have the authority to
take it and interpret and do something
with it
and because these models are big because
these air models are very very big
they're late to be less transparent
right
so they're not able to explain what they
do what decision they make and why they
make the decision so how much do i trust
the decision
and again the question again becomes is
it just parroting or learning is it able
to extrapolate so for example if it can
help me with today's situation if the
situation changes tomorrow right think
of an ai system that's uh
uh
giving guidance for a
cure for a disease what if the the virus
is market or a new kind of disease if
has come about is it going to be able to
help me uh can it extrapolate itself so
these are all questions that come up
when we look at these large systems that
you know less about
and and coming back to our own
system our own area where we deploy
products for our developers
you know number one we are kind of kind
of incorporating these into existing
products that have existed for over 20
years ago so we have to replace existing
pieces of existing code with these
models and what are these models these
models are just matrix forms so how do i
replace code with say stochastic
gradient descent and there is this whole
idea of software 2.0 that andres
karpathy wrote about a little while ago
and so we need to kind of re-architect
some of these systems to incorporate
these models into this system
we had other kind of challenges the
model footprint on the edge has to be
less than 30 megabytes and that's
a lot less than what the default models
you produce
and how does it interfere with the user
experience and typical developers i mean
difficult development process is an
analytical process
so if you interfere with the user
experience even if you make a good
recommendation the developer may not
like it right and the response time is
equally important right because
somebody's typing away and if the system
pops up and makes a recommendation
it cannot take more time that than
that is visible to the developer
and then there's a lot of privacy uh
constraints as well if i'm an enterprise
i may not share my data with
with
with the system so how do we how do the
system provide a client only model right
i mean i want to share my data i want to
keep my shared private data private and
um
i need a model that works for myself so
there's a lot of these questions that
have to be answered that are way beyond
just having a a smart algorithm that
will um do wonderful things with you
right we have to honor privacy we have
to honor security and we have to protect
from the rogues that could poison our ai
system by injecting bad code into the
into into the ecosystem
so with that we basically in mind we uh
built a transformer model again what is
it
the simple kind of transformer is a
generator model which is you're writing
some text are you writing some code and
the job is to predict the next token
right so for example if you're typing
out an outlook or gmail you know when
you're typing out text you see this
recommendation that comes up saying
you're likely to type this text that's a
kind of recommendation and in case of
code all we had to do was what is the
next token or the next sequence of
tokens you would type make a predicted
and be as right as possible so what we
had our first model was the generator
transformer model
which has a gpt model unlike the bullet
model that was used in the nlp community
now when we deployed there's a lot of
lessons learned like we we hit the
limits of data parallelism we need to
figure out how to incorporate model and
pipeline parallelism we need in order to
fit the model into the client we needed
to quantize them we need to do 16-bit
and intake arithmetic we need to distill
the model by removing layers by building
small student networks out of the large
models
right and we need to take advantage of
the parallelism the simply parallelism
that was available on the cpu right we
had to do other kinds of engineering
tricks like caching values in the client
and we had to do innovations in beam
search and sampling for faster imprint
inference and better recommendations
so these were
things that you had to do to push into
production make the developer happy and
make it work
right so you know with this in mind we
kind of said okay we got one thing right
so can we do other software engineering
tasks so one thing is we're going to
focus only on software engineering tasks
and can we achieve multiple software
engineering tasks with minimal amount of
pre-training costs which means when we
build these
foundational models you know it needs to
be learned know only about things that
are related to software engineering that
could be text that could be code that
could be documentation related to
software and we want to reuse these
models and we want to reuse the data for
new kinds of tasks
and we want significant flexibility in
fine tuning and influencing of these
models
and we also want to enable innovation in
software engineering so that's one of
the wonderful things about this is that
if you can create a system that you know
because we can come up with only so many
innovations but we put it out to the
community can the community innovate on
top of it so these were some of the
goals that we had and with that in mind
with the flexibility and the efficiency
that we wanted to create for our
ecosystem you know we designed our
system to have a certain architecture
so this this systems we don't compare in
scale to say gpd3 or something and
typical models are about a billion
parameters but what it has is an
architecture that is super flexible so
it contained inside the architecture is
an encoder kind of architecture which is
basically vert architecture commonly
used in nlp tasks it has a gpd
architecture which we saw for code
code recommendation in the first example
and so we could do things like code
completion we could do uh code quality
classification etc then it also has an
encoder decoder about sequence to
sequence model that that allows you to
do tasks like translation
or you know bug patching or unit test
generation etc so
we had we wanted to create an
architecture that's flexible enough to
fine tune for tasks that are relevant to
software engineering and can also add
more tasks as well another thing that
separates us from say you know what you
see in the typical nlp community where
they use
metrics like
the nlp metrics is is
it's not just how how close it is to the
world not at a distance right it's
beyond that how good is the program that
you generated how efficient is the
program they generate so we have our own
metrics called the plum metrics in order
to do that
and then you know we're making this
package available to be deployed using
say
azure or a cloud platform to into
production and also have layers of dog
fooding trying it out trying the model
offline before we can push to production
so this is kind of the general
architecture of the system that we built
it's called deep dev it's available on
deepdev.microsoft.com so you can you can
sign up download and build your own
fine-tuned tasks and it's trained on all
kinds of um you know code and
documentation and text data
so i'm going to give you a few examples
of how we use this to do a software
engineering task so one example would be
how can we generate whole methods from
specifications so the specifications
could be just function signatures or you
know
text or dot strings and um you know so
this uses a
encoder decoder model sequence sequence
model that basically translates from one
to the other i'm not going to go into
the details of it
it's very well written in the paper
described and
our results basically
number one showed that we at this scale
of parameters we can't use um
uh gpt model we need a sequence sequence
kind of model and then the second thing
we learned was we needed really the
programming program language
understanding metric we can't just use
the standard uh blue metrics or um
you know
perpetuity metrics that is used in nlp
right because we want to answer
questions like how
good is this generated code how
syntactically correct is it what are the
semantics is it executable is it
efficient and so on and so forth
um another example would be a transpiler
which basically says oh i've got code
written in one language i want to
translate this is very similar to the
example i started my talk with i want to
generate code written in another
language can i do that for free how do i
do that right
quite often programmers when they write
code they are looking for an api call
they want to know how to
how to do let's say
write a certain algorithm or
call a certain api
and sometimes this api may be available
in one language
but that may not be the language in
which the the program is programming so
in which case you might want to do
combined search with translation as well
here i'm going to talk only about
translation
so this again uses the sequence of
sequence model of the deep dev platform
that we have but during fine tuning it
does some clever things right number one
you need parallel data now what is
parallel data you need examples of code
that are equivalent in two languages so
let's say i'm i'm translating here in
this example python to c plus plus i
need examples of python code that's
equivalent to c plus plus so this is one
of the things that we feed into the
system when we do the fine tuning and
this is collected from sources where you
know if you have examples of assignments
or competition where you know a certain
task is done in multiple languages so we
mine these examples we curate them and
we produce equivalent examples for the
same task and then put that into the
into the data set that's used for fine
tuning another thing we do is that we do
back translation which means if you're
if you're going from python to c sharp
or c plus plus we go from c plus plus to
python as well and we do kind of
iterative training
again the details i'm going to skip it
to the paper but what we found by doing
all this and using the basically the the
foundational architecture of
deep dev we could get pretty good um uh
accuracy uh of translational java c
c-sharp and c-sharp to java
i'm going to give you another example
here is you know unit test generation is
a big task developers spend about 30
percent of the time writing unit tests
for the code they write it's important
part of our software engineering process
so the idea here was can we generate a
high quality unit test for the code that
was written uh for any piece of software
that's written so again using the the
model uh
as a platform we
you said the encoder decoder part of the
for part of the system and uh for fine
tuning we use the context of the the
method for the for which we call the
focal method so the the method for which
we want to generate the test code and
incorporate things like the fields in
the class the constructor of the class
etc etc and generate automatic test code
so here's an example here there's a
function called create float and
by
running it through the system it
generates um
you know test examples it basically
generates two research statements
instead of that and the way we measure
the goodness of these metrics is uh or
that this translation uh sorry the test
generation is how readable is it when it
generated it and what kind of test
coverage does it provide to the system
so these are the metrics of goodness
when we use the system for
um automatic unit test generation
um so one of the things through the
journey of
doing all of this stuff is we found that
offline metric is very different from
online metric and which is also very
very different from user metrics for
example offline matrix just provides us
with a baseline
metric to qualify for the next step now
dog fooding helps us further to
strengthen our trust in the models
and basically helps us you know we talk
to a handful of developers they try it
out we look at how how much does what
does their experience match with their
offline offline metric
and then when we deploy it we typically
tend to see much poorer scores in terms
of the metrics that whatever metrics we
might have but at the same time when we
do use the surveys we kind of learn
about how much user experience
interferes with the user's behavior and
complements r actually reduces
the quality of the algorithm metrics
provided with algorithms
so we believe that user experience plays
a huge role in bridging the gap between
user expectation and the goodness of the
algorithm
and
and we try hard we know in all of these
models when we deploy them into
production
user experience is not talked about
enough when we read papers in ai but
it's a very important part of
the system when we deploy these a models
into production so in summary we found
three foundational entities that have
helped us with innovation in this space
first there was grammars that i
described the use of grammars
effectively made automation possible
through code generators code generator
generators and translator generators and
so on where significantly less code had
to be written and code is generated
instead of being
written
and then came the big wave of big data
big data allowed us to create
data-driven products
with reasonably simple algorithms by
taking advantage of the volume of the
data and we could reduce information
friction we could create data-driven
products and
answer questions about causality
incentives and user behavior
and now we're in the golden age of ai
where we see huge innovations in gpu
hardware in data processing as well as
deep learning algorithms and this has
helped us build ai platform systems like
deep device described uh with reasonable
intelligence about a particular domain
in this case we are talking about
software engineering as a domain
and by using these foundational
platforms
that has a reasonable intelligence we
can achieve individual tasks of whether
it is automatic test generation or
merged conflict resolution or code
translation or code generation or code
completion all of that stuff we can do
with um you know
very very little work by just by fine
tuning so it has fundamentally changed
the way we developed productivity
software the way we build intelligent
products
now more recently we have been able to
combine all three we've been able to
take language elements like grammars and
flow graphs etc combined with that with
clever use of data for training and
retraining as well as for
fine-tuning and combine them with the
the
tasks that are driven by the ai models
to achieve even better uh results
of course you know a lot of other work
has to be done in order to get to the
next level now number one you know we
still talk about correctness what does
it mean to generate correct code or
produce results that are acceptable to
the user how do we create systems that
perform well without degrading you know
the user experience and then there is
this question about transparency of the
models how much do they know how much do
they learn and how transparent are these
models in explaining what they do
then there's this constant concern about
privacy and security while we have taken
several measures to make sure that you
know user information or
private information doesn't leak into
these models we it's a constant
challenge to make sure that it doesn't
happen or the the models or the data
doesn't get poisoned in a way that uh
you know privacy or security is violated
and finally this there's a big question
about fairness and bias now how good is
this data so that it is fair across all
the dimensions in which we use these
models and we avoid bias
so with that i want to thank you for
your attention this session and hope you
enjoy the rest of the conference thank
you
hello everybody my name is ukramore and
i am the vp of github next
github next is a group of researchers
within github who are exploring the
frontiers of software engineering
one of those frontiers is the use of ai
to make
developers more productive
and i'm extremely grateful to the
organizers and to you all here to give
me the opportunity to talk about github
co-pilot our most exciting project in
this space
github co-pilot was
is a collaboration between open ai and
github and literally dozens of people
have contributed i would however like to
uh acknowledge my two co-founders on the
project
alex rivley and albert ziegler and in
particular
uh albert's work will feature very much
later in this talk
for those of you who haven't seen
co-pilot before
i'd like to show you a little demo
in my spare time i like to read about
history and often that involves reading
old books
in languages that i do not understand
so for example on this slide there's a
page of a book about zebuch a little
village in malta it's in the book is in
italian
and i would like to
read this page but
i don't understand italian
so what i'm going to do is to write a
little app
that takes a picture like this
extracts the text in italian translates
it into english and then shows the
original paste page with the uh
translation next to it
so let's see how that works with
with copilot i'm here in vs code i've
already imported some libraries that
might be useful so
let's try and write the code
first we need to get the text
and i just said in english what i wanted
to do in a comment convert the image to
text in italian
when i hit the return button copilot
responds in grey text with a complete
implementation of this function
and if i like the implementation which
in case in this case i do i just hit the
tap key to accept it
next we actually need to translate that
text so
let's write a function for that
again i just say what i wanted to do
translate the text into
english once again co-pilot responds
with a complete implementation which i
accept by hitting the tab key
all right so remember that i said that i
actually want to
create a new image where we've got the
original image next to the translation
so we're now going to write a function
for that
i'll call it juxtapose
it takes an image and it takes a text
and let's describe what it should do
create a new image
okay so we want to create a new image
with the original image on the left and
the text on the right
let's give a little bit more detail
we want to make the image twice the
width of the original but the same
height
and finally
i'd like to display
the texts
invites
on a black background
so let's see what co-pilot makes of that
it does give me a complete
implementation which again i accept uh
it doesn't actually know that i'm
working on a macbook today and so it's
the location for the font is not quite
right so let's change that
and i want it a little chunkier
it would also be nice to shift the
text a little bit to the right so let's
add 32. with
okay
so now we need to put it all together
let's find
define a function process it takes an
image
and let's see what should that do
ah co-pilot has already figured it out
we want to get the text we want to
translate it and then juxtapose the
image and the text in english
so we accept that
and now we want to try that
note that every time i just hit the
return key and then tap to accept
the lead the co-pilot gives me
so let's execute that this is like going
to the nazca races we're now all waiting
to see whether a crash will happen
ah
it's almost right it's almost right but
not quite the text uh is actually uh
running off the page so we need to wrap
it
okay that seems pretty
good knows how to do that
so let's try that once again
and there you go
exactly what i wanted
the original text on the left and the
translation on the right what you've
seen is that copilot allows you to
write this sort of thing
without all those annoying web searches
that take you out of the flow you get
the advice you need right
inside your code editor
how does this actually work as you saw i
was typing my code in the rvs code
editor and every few keystrokes it sends
the editor contacts
to the github copilot service that does
a little bit of processing and then it
asks the openai codex model
what might come next to complete what
the the code that the
developer is currently working on
suggestions come back from codecs we cut
them to size to make sure that they're
uh make syntactic sense at that point in
the code and then they're displayed
in gray text then as you could see we
you hit the tab key to accept them
so
currently this is a new product it's in
preview and we really want to learn how
people are using it and how we can
improve it and so we're really grateful
to everyone who joined the preview but
they agreed to the telemetry terms this
gives us invaluable information as you
see we'll see shortly in order to
improve the ui but also to improve the
models and eventually the suggestions
themselves
so what you've seen is that
in some cases it works pretty well but
how good is it really
in order to answer that question we
created the test harness a test harness
that you point at github repositories
and
the harness will find
suitable target functions
in the in the source code to
give to the model
to fill in so a good target function is
one that has good test coverage
and also
a reasonable doc strength so we have
something to go by
in this graph on the left hand side the
success rate indicates how often the
model uh succeeded in creating a
solution that passed the unis unit test
and on the horizontal axis
are the number of shots the number of
temp attempts that the
model got in order to get this right now
there's actually two lines the red one
is the model that we launched with all
the way back in june
and the blue one is a new model that we
recently deployed and as you can see
it's massively better it's correct much
more often
than the old one and these are
improvements that we see all the time
and it's because of that because of
these improvements that i'm super
optimistic that this is just the
beginning there are still so many more
improvements that can be done uh we're
very confident that the model uh can uh
can get way better
in
in in synthesizing correct solutions
all right dr damore that's very nice
uh you've shown in a laboratory
experiments that you can generate code
that passed past more unit tests
but what about your users
do people actually
benefit by having such an improved model
in order to answer that question
we did an a b experiment we gave half of
our users the new model
and half of the users stayed on the old
model and then we looked at three
metrics the first of these metrics is
just the suggestions per user hour
if you use this thing for an hour
how often do you accept a suggestion and
if you accepted the suggestion
how often do you retain it so you don't
make any edits as you saw in the demo uh
it's
not uncommon but you get a suggestion
and then later you make a
change so
we we take it that if you left the
suggestion
alone for 30 seconds
that counts as a as a win so after a
suggestion is accepted we look 30
seconds later no edits that counts as a
as something that was retained verbatim
this is a good simple metric but
sometimes we want to drill down a little
bit deeper and for that we look at the
final shape the funnel shape of how many
completions were requested how many were
done were shown how many of the shown
ones were accepted and how many of the
accepted ones were retained so you go
see these completions go through each of
the stages you might think why
would you request a completion and not
show it well uh these requests requests
are issued spontaneously
we don't uh have the user explicitly
asked for them and so
the user may be typing and they just
continue typing and then by the time a
completion comes back um uh uh it's no
longer useful to use around we don't
actually we don't actually show it that
is also the reason that there is a
trade-off here a trade-off between
extremely powerful models that are
highly accurate
and less accurate models that aren't so
fast enough to be useful to users who
type at normal speed
and finally the third metric that we
looked at is the percent of code that is
actually written by copilot so
look at
the total amount of code that was edited
in a new session
and we asked ourselves the question how
much of that
a typical in typical or call for a
typical co-pilot user how much of that
was written by the model
this we believe is a pretty good true
measure of the benefit
all right so let's go through these
let's go through the results the
suggestions per user hour are when we
look over all programming languages yep
uh just as we would hope
the accepted solutions go up by 10 so
that's similar to the improvement we saw
for our passing unit tests very
encouraging
actually even more interesting the
increase in the number of solutions that
are kept verbatim is higher 14 more than
for the old
model
so this is good people actually like the
solutions look at them carefully and
decide
they will do fine
the results differ per programming
language and python from the very
beginning has been our primary focus so
python
our performance is already very good
it's a
much higher baseline to start from and
it's because of that that the
improvement is
significant but smaller than for the
other languages only four percent more
is accepted and
uh still also here uh more even more
a larger percentage is kept verbatim
okay so
uh when we drill down and look at the
funnel shape
well
almost everything is getting better
more
solutions are shown per request more are
accepted by shown more are kept verbatim
after acceptance
but
uh the first metric is actually down
um
we are speculating here but we think
maybe because the users are trusting
them all more and so they actually pause
and properly wait for
a suggestion to be uh to be given to
them
okay
so
now for the final metric
percentage of code written by co-pilot
so if we want to give a percentage of
the total amount of code written we
first have to
define what the total amount of code
written is uh we're going to look at
code that has changed at cochern and
we're only going to count additions and
the way we detect that
is that we look at the prompts for
consecutive requests so as you typing
every so often a new request is issued
and sent to the model
which we see in our telemetry and if
the problem became larger there's more
code that was before
we count that as an addition
however not if it changed too much if it
changes by more than 100 characters uh
you probably jumped around in a file or
you change you went even went to a
different file so we don't believe that
you typed that so we don't
count it
and we also not uh interested in just
the really small little uh little edits
we only consider sessions where more
than 500 characters are added
so that's the definition of the total
amount of code that was written in a
session
we then measure the copilot
contributions
as the length of the contributions
minus the number of changes that you
make to them
unless you make too many changes if you
change more than half of the suggestion
we count it as a total loss there
co-pilot didn't contribute anything
arguably it so i contributed negatively
so we only count
contributions
where the edits are
fairly minor less than half of the
characters
so here are the results
even the old model is actually quite a
high number for pi for for uh all
languages
16.3 percent of the code is written
by the artificial intelligence
for the new model it's even more 19
so this is very encouraging um
well when i first saw this graph what i
found even more encouraging is that both
the lines are going up both lines there
so we're running an exp a ap experiment
during the same time period
and of course both models are using the
same ui
and so what you see here reflected in
that increasing acceptances is that the
user experience improved or we're a
little bit more careful about the
bouncing we're a little bit more
careful about
making certain ui elements discoverable
um this has quite a big impact on the
number of
on the amount of code that was accepted
so
here is a
another way of looking at that data
for languages that are not python
we have a three percent increase
between the old model and the new model
and it's a large amount 18
but then look at python
it was 27 and now it's 29 almost a third
of the
amount of code
that people write when they're using
copilot with python almost the cells is
written by the ai i find that very
exciting very encouraging but it's only
the beginning
we expect many more improvements many
more improvements like this so we're
very confident that that number will be
way higher even in years time
okay
let me conclude
i've shown you github co-pilot i'll show
you in little uh a little demo
and
uh we've
looked at different ways of evaluating
how good co-pilot really is
we looked at the harness
which is really about how many unit
tests uh uh can we make it can can can
be passed by the uh by the model
so it's very much about program
correctness
we then use that user metrics looked at
user metrics unfortunately those are
pretty well correlated our users are are
quite discriminating
they accept more solutions
if they are of higher quality uh it's
only the beginning though and we very
much would like to hear your feedback
uh both on the whole idea of co-pilots
itself but also only these methods of
evaluating
how good the models are and how well
co-pilot is doing how helpful it is to
its users
so far co-pilot has only been used we've
only used the technology to help you uh
create new code
but we think that the same technology
can be
hugely helpful in almost every other
aspect of software development
in code review in refactoring in testing
so stay tuned for more announcements on
those topics
that's all i have to say today thank you
very much i look forward to the
discussions and feedback
thank you
okay thanks everybody for coming so i'm
going to talk today about this pesky
little problem that happens uh when you
do a git pull
and you have made changes to some piece
of source code that someone else has as
well and we're going to talk a little
bit about how we use both machine
learning and programming languages in
order to come up with safe program
merges
so before we dive in i want to give you
a go through a little bit of trivia get
people warmed up here so you can answer
at home i know this is a recording
a group of fish is called a
school
okay another one a group of kittens
is called a
litter okay so now the tough one now
that we're warmed up a group of software
engineers is called a
emerge conflict
okay
so emerge conflict is a drag on
collaborative software development right
it's happening all the time in the what
emerged how a merged conflict arises is
that we have some common base program
that two people call them a and b have
decided to edit they both make
independent changes and then ultimately
they need to merge their merge their
changes back into the main line now when
they do that one of the two a or b will
have to result if they've added the same
file will have to do a merge conflict
resolution
all right they'll basically have to have
to fix the com the conflict any conflict
that arises between editing the same
file
so what's pesky about merge conflicts is
that you can have a situation where if
you have continuous integration tests in
your development cycle
base a and b respectively can all pass
your continuous integration tests but
when you do emerge even if it's a silent
merge which is handled automatically for
you by tooling like git merge
the continuous integration test can fail
so merge conflicts are a major
productivity drain
on on developers right so so basically
there are many studies uh that have
shown this one of them is is on this
slide here basically 10 to 20 of all
merges have conflicts in collaborative
software development projects the thing
with merges is that particularly when
they get large is they're not always
straightforward in how to do the
resolution and as a consequence
developers oftentimes delay merging
those things for hours to days which
slows down the development cycle
likewise if they're very complex
sometimes developers will actually throw
out the changes that either they or the
other person has made sync up later on
with the teammate who did those changes
and then re-implement them after doing
uh throwing out that work so there's
reproduction of work
so my colleague chavender lihiri has a
very nice blog post recently
on safe program merges at scale and he
talks a little bit about this as a grand
challenge for program repair research i
encourage you to go take a look at that
and and the rest of this talk is kind of
uh modeled uh after this this this very
nice blog so what is a safe three-way
merge well there's been a bunch of work
on this in the academic community
most recently there was a great paper uh
in uppsala
where they formally verified what it
means to be safe
in the context of a three-way merge and
i'll i'll send you off to that paper to
read it to get a deeper understanding
but i'll give you an intuition
the intuition is that any test that
passes in a or b
should also pass in that resulting
merged program right so this is a very
nice um
way to view
uh the formal verification of a merge
from a programming language's standpoint
because you don't have to worry about
formally verifying a and having a spec
for a right it's a it's a relativistic
view
of of the of safety
and so that gets you a huge amount of
leeway and actually how they formally
verify
these programs now despite this really
great work it's very difficult to apply
at scale
so there's been a bunch of work um that
is as in the p inspired by the
programming language community that has
tried to make a safe three-way merge or
at least partially toward a safe
three-way merge so there's there's an
approach called structured merge where
what people do in this world uh is they
they lift the merge from working on on
lines of code
or less structured merge in other words
to to operating on ast elements and the
observation with this is that once
you've done that lifting it a large
number of of merge of conflicts can be
safely merged by taking advantage of
properties of those asts so concretely
if you have two java method declarations
you know that you can reorder them
without causing any kind of a
correctness issue
so the problem with these approaches um
while they're great is that they're
difficult to scale right if you come up
with a new if you want to do this for a
new language you have to go out and
build up the ast representation and
build algorithms then on top of those
difficult implement algorithms on top of
those asds
and despite the fact that they do make
some inroads into uh safety of the
resulting merges they provide
they're not guaranteed to be safe on all
merges so some of my colleagues and i
have been working for a while now on on
a machine learning inspired approach to
a three-way merge
and we just we call this a data-driven
approach where we go off and we mine
programmer actions so we go off to git
and we find places where people do a
resolution
we extract a big data set and then we
teach a model using machine learning uh
to merge to merge two programs um and
one of the great things that that came
out of this work uh and actually as a
necessity to make it work at all was
that we need to use some of the ideas
from safe program merge that program
that that was in that original group
paper in order to filter and produce a
high quality data set right we have to
throw out a lot of instances where the
developer potentially didn't do a safe
three-way marriage and by using those
insights we can get a very high quality
data set
and thus then our models once we've
trained on them are likely empirically
likely to produce a safe result so the
nice thing about this is that they're
easy to scale right if i come up with a
new language that i want to apply this
approach to i go off and i just have to
get data and train a model uh the
downside is that it's a less structured
merge and it you know despite the
empirical guarantees it definitely does
not give us any any formal guarantee of
safety
so i want to go into a little bit of
detail about how merge bert works
um so merge bird is built the the
architecture of merge bird is built off
of a very key observation that we made
and other people have made as well in
the literature um which is that most
merges when you actually look at them
they don't insert new tokens it's mostly
a reordering of existing tokens instead
by tokens i mean tokens in the actual
programming language
so if we take a look at the pane on the
left hand side here it's a line level
conflict that's what you would get if
you got if you ran git merge
so there's there's o with dot s which is
the original
common ancestor and then a and b have
both made edits now you'll see that both
a and b change to 10 to 11 except b also
added
an extra parameter to the max argument
function z
so if you look at this at the token
level and just do a a a a line
structured three-way merge um you'll get
that representation in in the middle
pane where now it's very clear where the
conflict is arising now what merge bert
does is it actually builds a
classification engine
on top of a finite set of actions to
pick which action at a token level
conflict should we take in order to
produce a resolved merge on the
right-hand side now in this case it's
simple the model just predicts uh take b
take the the edit from b
because it subsumes the meta for the
edit from a
um and so merge bur in the paper we'll
show you as we show there's a we have a
finite set of actions and so we've
turned this this
rather complex problem into a
classification task in order to produce
the pain on the right so that's the
architecture of how merged works if we
take a look at how merged works uh
in practice we looked at 25 000 java
programs on in our merges in 16 000
javascript merges
jdime operates on java
and if you look at the precision recall
on f1 you can see that merged bird on
java is significantly better on all
three so very concretely if you look at
precision which is a function of how
many times the tooling produced a
suggestion uh how accurate was it when
it produced that suggestion
merged
for both java and javascript is over 70
accurate uh while the existing
structured approaches are significantly
less
so with that i think there's a you know
we've learned a lot in trying to produce
uh safe program urges and we're not
there yet to going back to the blog post
that uh shivendu has put together um you
know one of the things that we really
want to think about is how do we how do
we guarantee safe merges at a massive
scale right we believe there's some
combination of machine learning and
programming languages that has to come
together in order to make this happen
but we're not there yet and one of the
very concrete metrics we'd like to throw
out to the community is to think about
what does it take to safely and
automatically merge millions of programs
um you know along the way we're going to
solve a lot of very hard technical
problems um one of which is you know and
i think a lot of ai for codes
tooling will have this problem right as
we have generate these models which can
produce larger and larger amounts of
code i think there's a very interesting
ui experience that we need to think very
hard about
that lets us think about why you know
how do we present uh these code
suggestions to users so that they can
actually understand them in a reasonable
amount of time right it's it's somewhat
easy if a tooling product if a merge
resolution tool produces a two-line
resolution the developer can very
quickly eyeball that and understand what
it why the model made the choices it did
or what the what the resulting code is
doing if that turns out to be a hundred
lines of code it becomes much harder
and so having some sort of amount of
provenance or understanding in the ui
experience itself about what that merge
what the model did and why it made its
choices is going to be paramount to
getting the developers to take it to
take these tools
so with that i'd like to thank my
collaborators there's a whole host of
people here who worked both within
microsoft as well as outside
we've had a great set of interns that
have helped drive this work to where
it's at
if you're interested in coming and
working with us to understand how
programming language research and
machine learning research can help
solve these very hard software
engineering problems please don't
hesitate to send us an email thanks so
much